paris without people no this isn't an  apocalypse this is paris in china  tian du chang is a luxury real estate  development and paris lookalike located  in hangzhou china as china became the  world's fastest growing economy real  estate developments popped up all over  the country  some modeled from famous western cities  this chinese paris started construction  in 2007  and while the city is built to hold 10  000 people only 2 000 live there full  time making it feel more like a ghost  town  the lack of people could be linked to  where tiandu chang is located surrounded  by miles and miles of farmland  the eiffel tower replica is about  one-third the size of the original and  stands surrounded by copycat french  architecture  and just like the original it's a great  backdrop for newlyweds looking for an  everlasting memory  you know what they say imitation is the  sincerest form of flattery